when you begin learning a new language
it's absolutely critical that you start
things off on the right foot and spend
your first three months wisely
as they say a good start is half the
battle
hi my name is luca from lucarampeda.com
and today i'm going to talk to you about
the 10 things i do whenever i start
learning a new language
i set a starting date and stick to it
it's not uncommon to meet people who say
that they want to learn a new language
or that
they've even decided to start learning
one however
when you ask these people when they're
actually going to get started learning
they usually don't have an answer for
you they give you vague answers like
someday or soon or as soon as i'm done
with final exams and then when it comes
down to it
they never actually start this is
probably the greatest and most
common sin of language learning never
actually starting to learn
even though you know you want to the
cause of this of course
is procrastination just like exercising
eating right
and learning an instrument we all know
deep down that
language learning is a challenge and so
we try to trick ourselves into
putting it out forever i can fall victim
to this too that's why
whenever i decide to learn a new
language i take the time
to fix an actual start date for my
learning
and put it on my calendar in my case i
like to begin learning languages
in september it's an old habit back from
my school days
since september is when each new school
year
would start in your case all you need to
do is to pick a start date that is
significant
for you it can be any date or any time
of year
so long as you stick to it again the
purpose of setting a date is to beat
procrastination to give yourself a sense
of urgency
of motivation and of starting a new
exciting adventure once you set such a
date
you know that there's no going back
you're going to learn your target
language and it's going to happen
on that date circled right on your
calendar
i use time boxing to schedule my daily
learning language learning
is a long journey when starting out on
the journey it's easy to look at in the
vast
distance in front of you and become
overwhelmed with
just how much work there is to do before
you reach your goal
fortunately there's an easy antidote to
this feeling
a daily action plan you see though the
journey is intangibly long
it is made up of smaller parts that are
much easier to understand
days weeks and months of these
the most important is the day if you can
master your daily language learning
schedule
and do that over and over and over again
then reaching your long-term goal is
just
inevitable and when i say mastering your
schedule
i just mean finding a set amount of time
every day
in which you can learn and practice your
target language i do this through an
easy technique called
time boxing i'll break down my day into
fixed blocks of time
usually ranging from 30 to 60 minutes
and when i start a new language i make
sure that my learning time
gets the most special block of the day
the first
30 to 60 minutes after i wake up even at
the beginning a new language does not
have to demand
any more time than that unless you want
to i visualize my future self using the
language
motivation is one of the most important
resources
in any language learner's arsenal
however
it's not always easy to come by even if
you start learning with enthusiasm
that single burst of motivation is not
likely to last
very long especially once learning
becomes
more challenging as i said earlier
language learning is a long
journey to reach fluency and beyond you
need to be able to create enough
motivation to fuel
your learning over the long term to
create the motivation and need to start
learning and keep learning a new target
language i use a technique
called visualization visualization is
the act of using your imagination
to project yourself into the future and
imagine what life will be like
when you've attained a specific goal
when i use visualization
i imagine myself as a highly skilled
learner of my target language
i picture myself traveling to where my
target language is spoken
having lively conversations with natives
and making deep and compelling
friendships
through visualization is a mental tool i
don't just picture a few compelling
images and call it a day
instead once i've imagined those future
scenarios i write them down in my
notebook
and keep those notes with me as i study
once i have my visualization written
down
it serves as an endless source of
motivation which is just
as useful far along my journey as it is
in the very beginning
it keeps me focused on my compelling
future and gives me the boost i need
to keep going even when learning is
difficult
choose one interesting resource to start
with thanks to the internet it's almost
too easy nowadays to fall into the trap
of spending hours and hours and hours
looking for the best possible beginner
resource and never actually deciding
which one to use even worse it's even
possible to buy too many resources and
then
spend all of your time switching back
and forth between them never confident
which one you're actually going to stick
with
for the long term i combat this problem
by restricting myself to spending
only a short amount of time looking for
resources before starting
after i've done an hour or two research
into the kinds of resources i like to
use
i pick one resource and then begin my
learning
on top of all that i avoid the trap of
endlessly switching between resources
by making a pledge put simply i promised
myself to use
my one chosen resource for at least
three months
before moving on to something else this
gives me enough time to fully test out
the resource
and absorb the knowledge or skills that
the specific resource
is trying to teach me without getting
distracted by all of the other shiny
resources out there
i minimize distractions to learn
something well requires
your full focus and attention this is
something we may all intuitively
understand
but in reality it's easier said than
done in today's digital age we are
almost constantly distracted 100
of the time at any moment the majority
of us are under attack by delusion phone
calls
emails text messages instagram
notifications
and advertisements they come from all
directions as well
any internet connected device be it your
phone tablet smartwatch or even your
e-book reader has the potential to bury
you in distracting notifications
if you want to seriously make progress
in the new language you've chosen to
learn
you need to figure out how you're going
to protect yourself
from all of these distractions
personally
i'm a bit of a digital minimalist when i
sit down for my daily language learning
session
i don't use my phone at all i do use my
computer but only for audio playback
if for some reason i absolutely have to
use a web browser
i make sure to close or minimize any
distracting tabs
for everything else i like to go old
school and stick to paper and pencil i
take a lot of notes when i learn and are
really enjoying writing things by hand
doing this really helps me keep focused
and learning in this way has
none of the potential drawbacks that
learning with apps or computer programs
tends to have in general if you're
starting out learning a new language
then you need to train your focus muscle
you can start doing this by keeping your
phone
and computer in do not disturb mode
while you learn
and even by blocking facebook and social
media on your phone the combination of
eliminating potential external
distractions and purposefully
trying to stay more focused will help
you get more value
from each learning period and help you
waste
less of your valuable time if you like
to learn more about staying focused and
minimizing distractions then i've
included links to a few resources
in the description box so make sure you
check those out i write my notes by hand
when you sit down to learn it may seem
faster to top
out your notes rather than write them by
hand however
typing requires you to remain in close
proximity to your computer and phone and
as i mentioned just a moment ago
interacting with technology while
learning
can expose you to dozens upon dozens of
distracting notifications
writing notes by hand may seem like the
slower less fancy option but in truth it
has a number of surprising benefits
first though handwriting takes more
effort than typing
the extra physical work that goes into
handwriting can actually help you focus
on the details
that you're actually committing to the
page
studies have actually proven that the
physical act of handwriting can help you
memorize
what you're learning more effectively
and since language learning requires
a lot of memorization every little bit
helps
of course there are still serious
benefits to having digital notes
i for example keep my most important
notes filed away in a series of google
docs but the trick here is to write your
notes by hand first
and convert the most important stuff to
digital stuff
later i tackle pronunciation from the
very beginning
pronunciation can be one of the most
difficult parts of learning any language
but it's generally the most important
why
because if no one can understand what
you're saying then it doesn't really
matter
how many words you know does it good
pronunciation skills are essential for
effective communication in any foreign
language
and that's why i personally focus on
them from the very beginning i've also
learned the hard way what can happen
if you don't prioritize pronunciation
back when i was learning swedish i had
ignored a key feature of the swedish
sound system
something called pitch accent and to
this day my pronunciation still suffers
a little bit why do i still struggle
because pronunciation skills are at
their core
just a series of physical habits that
are formed over time
if you develop the habit of pronouncing
something in the wrong way
as i did with swedish it becomes
incredibly difficult to
undo the habit later and then relearn it
the correct way because of all that i
believe it's very important to focus on
building the right pronunciation habits
from the very first day of learning pay
attention to the combination of
consonants and vowels focus on these
sounds in short sentences
read and repeat out loud experiment you
can even use tools such as the ipa
that is the international phonetic
alphabet to help you learn to articulate
specific sounds
i have left the link in the description
box if you'd like to learn more
i use a learning method that works well
for me there are a billion
and one language learning methods out
there possibly even more
as a beginner learner it's daunting to
see all the possibilities and avenues
you can explore
just to learn a single language and then
be expected to pick one
just one to start with but that's what
you must do
at the start of your journey the most
important thing is to spend more time
learning
and less time deliberating over your
options to start
pick one method and commit to testing it
out for a limited period of time
like six months or one year then
at the end of that period think
critically about how well that method
worked for you
if you find that your chosen method
worked great
however if it didn't work then the next
thing you need to do
is pick a new method to experiment with
for a period of time it may seem tedious
but this trial and error process
is something that every language learner
must go through
this is because there's no one best
method for every learner
instead different methods work well for
different people
in my case i've been learning languages
for 30 years
it took me several years of learning and
experimenting before i stumble upon my
bidirectional translation method which i
now use to start
every new language i learn however even
that method isn't fixed
i revise it constantly and it evolves
with each new language
so if you want to find the method that
works best for you
then you need to do something similar
experiment
try new things and reflect on how
different techniques work for you
after a while you'll become much more in
tune with how you learn
and you'll be able to find your ideal
language learning method as a result
i focus on getting exposure to language
first and then
i worry about grammar most people who
have attempted to learn languages in
school
tend to see grammar as the most
important thing to learn as a beginner
as a result of my years of practice i
disagree with this heavily when i begin
a new language the most important thing
is to get daily exposure to enjoyable
and comprehensible input
in my target language i need to hear how
the language sounds
see how the words are written and
observe firsthand how native speakers
use their mouths and body language to
express
themselves in the language following the
famed pareto principle
i spend at least eighty percent of all
my learning time
attempting to absorb this comprehensible
input
the remaining twenty percent of time is
what i use to focus on
grammar for example i do occasional look
at grammar explanations online or in
textbooks but
only when i need to clarify an obscure
point or figure out something i could
not
understand just through context the best
thing about all this
this 80 20 balance between
comprehensible input and grammar
learning
will actually require you to spend less
time explicitly
learning grammar over the long term this
is because the frequent exposure to
interesting and comprehensible content
will gradually train your brain to
grasp grammar patterns implicitly
meaning that
even if you do need to occasionally look
at a grammar book to clarify something
you'll be able to grasp the concept much
more quickly
than you would otherwise i keep a
journal considering how long the
language learning journey can be
i've always found it useful to keep
track of the process
by maintaining a language learning
journal this can be
incredibly beneficial for many reasons
first and foremost it
helps me see my progress and keep an eye
on just
how much work i'm putting into my
language learning on a daily basis
secondly it allows me to store notes and
other observations
that may be useful in the future for
example if i find that
a specific technique or resource is
really benefiting my learning
then i make a note of it in my notebook
and then
later on when i review my notes to
determine how to improve my learning
method
see tip number eight i can use that
information to make positive changes
in my technique and learning schedule i
recommend that every language learner
keep a journal like this
it doesn't have to be super involved or
take up too much of your time
just spend two to five minutes writing
down notes and observations in your
notebook at the end
of every learning session and you'll be
surprised
just how much help those observations
can be later on
down the line so there you have it these
are 10 of the most important things i do
when begin learning any new language the
first few months of learning are the
most
delicate stage of the process so
implementing these techniques and
strategies
really helped me lay a solid foundation
and get ready for the intermediate
and advanced stages of my learning if
you implement these techniques
you'll be able to get off to a strong
start as well thanks for watching the
video
if you liked it please remember to
subscribe or even share it with your
friends
and if you want more information about
anything i've discussed here
please take a look in the description
box where i have even included an
extensive article on this topic with
more useful information
and bonus resources again and as always
thanks for watching
[Music]
you